This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Picture for a minute. Los Angeles, the grand marquee's downtown, the Spanish-style mansions in the hills, that Jetsons like diners and drive-ins. Los Angeles is an architectural popery. It's the kind of place where if you want to go and build a house that looks like a Dutch colonial
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。想象一下这样的画面：洛杉矶，市中心宏伟的剧场、山坡上西班牙风格的豪宅、宛如《杰克逊一家》里那样的美式餐厅和免下车餐馆。洛杉矶的建筑风格包罗万象。在这里，如果你想建造一栋看起来像荷兰殖民时期风格的房子，
or a mansion with Doric columns or a sleek modernist flat roof thing, that's fine. Anything goes. That's Avery Trouffleman. In Los Angeles, architecturally, there are no rules, no unifying style. Because for people flocking to Hollywood in the 1930s, 40s and 50s, the growing city gave them an opportunity to build whatever kind of house they wanted, French chateau, futuristic modern, Italian
或者带有多立克柱式的豪宅，抑或是线条流畅的现代主义平顶建筑，都没问题。百无禁忌。那是埃弗里·特鲁夫曼。在洛杉矶，建筑上没有规则，也没有统一的风格。因为对于20世纪30、40和50年代蜂拥至好莱坞的人们来说，这座不断发展的城市为他们提供了一个机会去建造他们想要的任何房子，法式城堡、未来主义现代风格、意大利
villa, whatever. And there was this one particular architect who could do it all and do it well. And his name was Paul Revere Williams. Paul Williams' contribution to American architecture can be described in a number of different ways. This is architect Phil Freelon. He was an incredibly gifted residential designer. And on the West Coast, particularly in Los Angeles, he was known for designing residences of a number of Hollywood stars.
别墅，应有尽有。而且当时有一位特别的建筑师，他能驾驭所有这些风格并且做得非常出色。他的名字叫保罗·里维尔·威廉姆斯。保罗·威廉姆斯对美国建筑的贡献可以从许多不同的方面来描述。这位是建筑师菲尔·弗里隆。他是一位天赋异禀的住宅设计师。在西海岸，特别是在洛杉矶，他以设计众多好莱坞明星的住宅而闻名。
Paul Williams designed Frank Sinatra's Bachelor Pad, a mansion for Lucille Ball and Desiarnes. He made additions on the Beverly Hills Hotel and the Palm Springs Tennis Club. He also helped design the Stately and Sparse LA County Courthouse. And if you've ever flown into LAX, you can see this really space-age-y-looking structure, almost like a flying saucer with long legs that landed in front of Terminal 1.
保罗·威廉姆斯曾为弗兰克·辛纳屈设计单身公寓，为露西尔·鲍尔和德西·阿纳斯设计豪宅。他参与扩建了贝弗利山酒店和棕榈泉网球俱乐部。他还协助设计了庄重而简洁的洛杉矶县法院。如果你曾乘飞机抵达洛杉矶国际机场（LAX），你会看到这样一个极具太空时代感的结构，它几乎就像一个长着长腿的飞碟，降落在1号航站楼前方。
That's called the theme building, and Paul Williams was part of the team that made that. And the sheer volume of his work, he produced over 3,000 projects in his career, in his 50-year career. And that's quite an achievement. No one is exactly sure how many buildings he worked on. It's certainly in the thousands, but still, he was largely an invisible figure in architectural history, as well as Los Angeles' history.
这座建筑被称为主题航站楼，保罗·威廉姆斯正是打造它的团队成员之一。他作品的数量极其庞大，在他50年的职业生涯中，他完成了超过3000个项目。这绝对是一个了不起的成就。没有人能确切知道他究竟参与设计了多少栋建筑。这个数字肯定在数千之多，然而在建筑史以及洛杉矶的历史中，他很大程度上依然是一个默默无闻的人物。
He designed everything from mentions, luxury hotels, and car dealerships to hospitals, housing projects, and public schools. In addition to the variety of Williams commissions, he could work in a huge variety of styles. Seriously, if you pick two of his buildings at random, in most cases, you'd never know that the same architect made them both. So, he really didn't have a particular signature move or form or material usage that you could drive up and say, that's a Paul Wienes building. But if you look at the body of work,
他设计的建筑无所不包，从豪宅、豪华酒店、汽车销售店到医院、保障房项目和公立学校。除了威廉姆斯的委托项目种类繁多之外，他还能够驾驭极其丰富的建筑风格。说真的，如果你随机挑选他的两座建筑，在大多数情况下，你绝不会猜到这两座建筑出自同一位建筑师之手。因此，他真的没有什么标志性的设计手法、固定形态或特定的材料运用，让你开车路过时能脱口而出：“这是一栋保罗·威廉姆斯的建筑。”但是，如果你审视他的整体作品，
there is a level of excellence and a consistency in the quality of the work, not necessarily in a stylistic manner. He is the architect who helped make the multi-style style of Los Angeles. And Los Angeles, in turn, helped make him. In Los Angeles, Paul Williams was able to build a career for himself that he probably couldn't have had
你会发现其中流露出卓越的水准和一以贯之的品质，尽管这并非体现在某种固定的风格上。他正是那个塑造了洛杉矶多元风格的建筑师。而洛杉矶，反过来也成就了他。在洛杉矶，保罗·威廉姆斯得以开创自己的职业生涯，而这作为一名非裔美国建筑师，他在美国其他任何地方
anywhere else in America as an African-American architect. Paul Williams, African-American architect, who was much more than an African-American architect, he was simply one of the best architects of the 20th century. This is Karen Hudson, Paul Williams' biographer, and also his granddaughter. I was very close to her, my girl, a black away. Hudson says the Los Angeles, her grandfather grew up in.
可能都无法实现。保罗·威廉姆斯，这位非裔美国建筑师，其成就远不止于一位非裔美国建筑师那么简单，他简直到可以说是20世纪最伟大的建筑师之一。这位是凯伦·哈德森，保罗·威廉姆斯的传记作家，也是他的孙女。“我跟他很亲近，我是个黑皮肤女孩。”哈德森说，她祖父成长时期的洛杉矶，
Back in the early 1900s, was pretty different from what it is now. I mean, it was open spaces. He was born downtown, Ayson, Santhip. You know downtown was a heart of LA. We were talking in 1894. And in 1894 when Williams was born Los Angeles was pretty much a small downtown surrounded with bean fields and orange groves and the wild Pacific. And the population of LA was skyrocketing. From 1890 to 1900 the city doubled from 50,000 to 100,000 residents in just 10 years.
早在20世纪初，跟现在有着很大的不同。我的意思是，那时到处都是开阔地。他在市中心出生，在一个叫……你知道的，市中心是洛杉矶的心脏。我们说的是1894年。在1894年威廉姆斯出生时，洛杉矶基本上只是一个被豆田、橘林和汹涌的太平洋环绕的小市中心。洛杉矶的人口正在飞速增长。从1890年到1900年，这座城市的人口在短短10年内翻了一番，从5万人激增至10万人。
The growing city was full of people that had come west for a better life. Paul Williams' parents were from Memphis and had moved to Los Angeles just before he was born. They came to California for their health because they both had tuberculosis. And that's how he was orphaned before he was four. Williams was raised by foster parents. He had a brother who was nine years older than him who was raised in a different family and died at a young age of pneumonia. Without much of a family of his own, Williams spent a lot of time in the neighborhood,
这座不断扩张的城市里挤满了为了追求更好生活而来到西海岸的人们。保罗·威廉姆斯的父母来自孟菲斯，就在他出生前不久搬到了洛杉矶。他们为了健康来到加利福尼亚，因为两人都患有肺结核。这就是为什么他在四岁之前就成了孤儿。威廉姆斯是由养父母抚养长大的。他有一个比他大九岁的哥哥，被寄养在另一个家庭里，却在很小的时候就死于肺炎。由于缺乏真正的家庭关爱，威廉姆斯花了很多时间在社区里转悠，
in downtown LA, which was full of immigrants from all over the world. I mean, he talks about learning conservation and gardening and things from the Japanese kids in the neighborhood, and so you sort of soaked all that up. In this diverse group of kids all went to school together, even though Paul Williams remembers being the only black kid. There were no segregated schools in LA. There weren't that many black kids, but they weren't segregated. This would be instrumental later in life.
在洛杉矶市中心，那里到处都是来自世界各地的移民。我的意思是，他谈到从社区的日本孩子那里学习保护自然、园艺之类的东西，所以他基本上把这些都吸收了。这群背景各异的孩子都在同一所学校上学，尽管保罗·威廉姆斯记得自己是唯一的黑人小孩。洛杉矶没有实行种族隔离学校。虽然黑人孩子没那么多，但他们并没有被隔离。这在他人生的后阶段起到了至关重要的作用。
When his high school connections would prove very valuable in Paul Williams' career. It's hard to say exactly where Williams desired to be an architect came from. He did have a natural talent for drawing, and then somehow he learned that architecture was a profession, and then, resolutely decided it was for him, which is kind of incredible when you think about it. He never knew another architect, never really even heard of another architect when he was young. When Williams told his high school guidance counselor that he wanted to practice architecture, he was told to give it up. He should not try to be an architect.
当时他在高中时期积累的人脉在保罗·威廉姆斯的职业生涯中证明了其巨大的价值。很难说威廉姆斯想要成为建筑师的愿望究竟从何而来。他确实有着与生俱来的绘画天赋，后来不知怎的，他了解到建筑学是一门职业，然后，他坚决认定这就是他想做的事，现在想来这真是有些不可思议。他年轻时从未认识过其他建筑师，甚至从未听说过其他建筑师。当威廉姆斯告诉他高中的升学顾问自己想从事建筑行业时，对方劝他放弃。他劝他不要尝试去当建筑师。
He should be a doctoral lawyer, because black people would always need doctors and lawyers. And white people would not hire him as an architect and black people couldn't afford him. So he should just give up. Didn't happen. Williams didn't go to architecture school. Instead, he attended different art schools and engineering school,
他应该去当一名医生或律师，因为黑人永远需要医生和律师。白人不会雇佣他当建筑师，而黑人又雇不起他。所以他还是趁早放弃吧。事实并非如此。威廉姆斯没有去读建筑学校。相反，他上了不同的艺术学校和工程学校，
just cobbling together the skills he needed in drafting, landscaping, and materials, before he was certified as a contractor in 1915. And then came the challenge of actually getting hired. In his own notes, he said he got dressed in his best suit, and which he probably only had one for church, but best suit had his little briefcase and he went knocking on doors. He approached all the architects in the area
一点一点拼凑出他在制图、景观设计和材料学方面所需的技能，并在1915年获得了承包商资格认证。接下来面临的挑战是如何真正被人雇佣。他在自己的笔记中提到，他穿上了自己最好的西装——那可能也是他唯一一套只在去教堂时穿的西装，拿着他的小公文包，开始挨家挨户敲门。他拜访了当地所有的建筑师，
that he admired and showed them his portfolio. They all said no. But if they smiled when they said no, then he went back the next day and kept knocking. And finally he had two offers, one for $3 a week, maybe five, and one for nothing. But he took the job that was for nothing because he thought he would learn more and be in a better position to advance. And after the first week they started paying him.
那些他十分敬佩的建筑师，并向他们展示了自己的作品集。他们都拒绝了。但如果他们在说“不”时面带微笑，他第二天就会再去，继续敲门。最后他得到了两份工作邀请：一份是每周3美元，也许是5美元；另一份则是零报酬。但他接受了那份零报酬的工作，因为他认为这样能学到更多东西，并能处于更有利的发展地位。而在第一周过后，他们开始付给他薪水了。
Paul Williams worked for a landscape architect, a residential architect, and a commercial architect before he was licensed to practice in California in 1921. The following year, he started his own firm, Paul R. Williams and Associates. Williams's first solo commission was a house for a well-connected high school friend, and his neighborhoods in Los Angeles blossomed word about Williams' spread. In the 20s or early 30s, if you go to dinner at somebody's house, because they have a new house, they say, who's your architect? There's one more, one more, one more.
保罗·威廉姆斯先后为一位景观建筑师、一位住宅建筑师和一位商业建筑师工作过，之后于1921年获得了在加利福尼亚州独立执业的资格。第二年，他创办了自己的事务所——保罗·R·威廉姆斯联合事务所（Paul R. Williams and Associates）。威廉姆斯接手的第一个独立委托项目是为一位人脉广泛的高中同学设计一栋房子，随着他在洛杉矶的社区里名声大噪，关于威廉姆斯的传言也开始流传开来。在20世纪20年代或30年代初，如果你去别人家吃晚饭，因为他们搬了新家，他们就会问：“你的建筑师是谁？”一个接一个，源源不断。
Williams had an impeccable sense of scale. And he knew just how to situate a structure on a property to make best use of beautiful views and sunlight. He helped create what would come to be known as the Hollywood style, that opulent mixture of Mediterranean, European, and colonial influences, with swimming pools and sweeping staircases. It's a rich and sumptuous sensibility, but Paul Williams kept these mentions very clean and classy. Paul R. Williams and associates grew quickly and became renowned.
威廉姆斯对空间尺度有着无可挑剔的敏锐感知。他非常清楚如何在宅基地上布局建筑，从而最大限度地利用美丽的景观和阳光。他协助开创了后来被称为“好莱坞风格”的建筑流派——那是地中海风情、欧洲风情和殖民地风情的奢华融合，往往配有游泳池和气势宏大的楼梯。这是一种丰富而华丽的审美品位，但保罗·威廉姆斯却能将这些豪宅设计得极为清爽高雅。保罗·R·威廉姆斯联合事务所迅速发展壮大，并声名远播。
Although some clients would be taken aback when they met Williams. Because you know they may have read about him, you know, may have heard about him, but they didn't realize he was black. He didn't want people to be uncomfortable. And often they were. I mean it's one thing to hire somebody, it's one thing to think that he's the best around and you want the best around. It's another thing to think that he's the best around and you want the best around. It's another thing to actually touch him.
尽管有些客户在见到威廉姆斯时会感到大吃一惊。因为你知道的，他们可能阅读过关于他的报道，可能听说过他，但他们并没有意识到他是个黑人。他不想让人感到尴尬。而他们往往确实感到尴尬。我的意思是，雇佣某人是一回事，认为他是周围最优秀的、并且你想要最好的是一回事。而真正去触碰他，又是另一回事。
Many of his white clients had never interacted with a black professional before. Williams had to find ways to work around white people's discomfort with him. He would not put people in a position where they felt like they had to shake his hand if they didn't want to. So he would put his hands at his pockets or behind his back. And Williams also recognized that many clients wouldn't want to take a seat next to him. And so to make them feel comfortable and to possibly persuade people who weren't sure
他的许多白人客户此前从未与黑人专业人士打过交道。威廉姆斯不得不寻找方法来缓解白人面对他时的不适感。他不会把人置于一种“如果他们不想的话，却不得不跟他握手”的境地。因此，他会把双手插在口袋里或背在身后。威廉姆斯还意识到，许多客户可能不愿意坐在他身旁。为了让他们感到舒适，并尽可能说服那些对
about having this black man, he could sit on one side of the desk, you'd be on the other side. And he would ask you, you know, do you want a formal living room, do you want a formal dining room, do you want a din because you have little kids, do you want this, do you want a formal living room? Do you want a formal dining room? Do you want a den? Because you have little kids. Do you want this? Do you want that?
雇用这位黑人男子心存犹豫的人，他可以坐在办公桌的一侧，而你坐在另一侧。他会问你，你知道的：“你想要正式的起居室吗？你想要正式的餐厅吗？因为你有小孩，你想要一个休闲室吗？你想要这个吗？你想要正式的起居室吗？你想要正式的餐厅吗？你想要休闲室吗？因为你有小孩。你想要这个吗？你想要那个吗？”
And then facing the client opposite the table, Paul Williams would sketch out a vision of the house, upside down, so that it faced the client. And he would sketch it upside down and come alive before your eyes. And I never interviewed anyone who saw him do it, who did not just light up as soon as we talked about it. It was like you should have seen him.
然后，坐在桌子对面面对着客户，保罗·威廉姆斯会勾勒出房子的设计构想，而且是倒着画的，这样图案正好面向客户。他会倒着把图画出来，让设计在你的眼前生动呈现。我从未采访过任何看过他这样作画的人，在谈到这个话题时他们的眼睛不是立刻放光的。那感觉就像是：“你真该亲眼看看他当时的样子。”
You've heard the expression ginger Rogers did everything for the stared at except backwards and in high heels. Well Paul Williams did everything his white peers did except upside down and better. Williams was not the first architect to draw upside down, but it's indicative of the lengths he went to accommodate his white clients. He always dressed impeccably and worked tirelessly. He once wrote about a meeting with a potential client who warned
你听过这样的说法：金格·罗杰斯（Ginger Rogers）完成了弗雷德·阿斯泰尔所做的一切，只是她是倒着跳的，而且还穿着高跟鞋。嗯，保罗·威廉姆斯完成了他的白人同行们所做的一切，只是他是倒着画的，而且做得更好。威廉姆斯并不是第一个倒着画图的建筑师，但这表明了他为了迁就白人客户而做出的巨大努力。他总是着装无可挑剔，工作不知疲倦。他曾在一篇手记中写到与一位潜在客户的会面，对方警告
Williams that he was also speaking with a number of other architects. The potential client asked how soon Williams could submit preliminary drawings. Four o'clock tomorrow afternoon said Williams. The client thought it was impossible because all the other architects had asked for two or three weeks. And you can bet that yes, Paul Williams delivered that plan at four o'clock the next day as promised. But he didn't tell the client that he had worked for 22 hours straight without eating or sleeping. He felt like he had to be light years better just to be accepted.
威廉姆斯说，他当时也在与许多其他建筑师交谈。潜在客户问威廉姆斯多久能交出初步图纸。“明天下午四点，”威廉姆斯说。客户认为这不可能，因为其他所有建筑师都要求两到三周。你可以打赌，没错，保罗·威廉姆斯正如承诺的那样，在第二天下午四点交出了那份图纸。但他没有告诉客户，他已经连续工作了22个小时，没有吃饭也没有睡觉。他觉得为了被接受，自己必须比别人优秀不知多少倍。
And, you know, often he wasn't accepted. Sometimes Williams was unwelcome in the very places he was designing. And even after he had earned the respect of his clients, he had to tolerate mistreatment from subcontractors and painters and plumbers. You know, you hire him to do your home and then some of the sub people who are working on the home are like, I'm not taking orders from this black guy. It's a regular kind of thing. Throughout his career, even as he designed mansions for wealthy clients, Williams also designed affordable homes for middle-class Angelinos.
而且，你知道的，很多时候他并没有被接受。有时，威廉姆斯在他所设计的那些地方并不受欢迎。甚至在他赢得客户的尊重之后，他还得忍受来自分包商、油漆工和水管工的虐待。你知道的，你雇他来设计你的家，然后一些在家里工作的分包人员却说：“我不会听从这个黑人家伙的命令。”这是一种常见的情况。在他的整个职业生涯中，甚至在为富裕客户设计豪宅的同时，威廉姆斯也为中产阶级的洛杉矶人设计经济适用房。
Any published books of inexpensive construction patterns that anyone could use to build a home of their own. You could send in for $10 and get a floor plan for your house. Williams also worked on a number of projects specifically for black institutions, including buildings on Howard University's campus in DC and the 28th Street, William C.A., which is in a historically black neighborhood in L.A. 28th year, why I was very important to him, he put in the facade likenesses of Frederick Douglass and Booker D. Washington because he believed that if young black boys could see that excellence every day as they walked in,
任何人都可用来建造自己房屋的廉价建筑模式出版书籍。你可以寄去10美元，就能得到你房子的平面图。威廉姆斯还参与了许多专门为黑人机构开展的项目，包括华盛顿特区霍华德大学校园内的建筑，以及位于洛杉矶历史悠久的黑人社区的第28街威廉·C·A公寓。第28街公寓对他来说非常重要，他在外墙上加入了弗雷德里克·道格拉斯和布克·T·华盛顿的肖像，因为他相信，如果年轻的黑人男孩每天走进去时都能看到这种卓越，
it would make them a different kind of person. He did a lot of charitable work, he did lots of things for children, and not just in the African American community. When he designed St. Jude's research hospital in Memphis, he did it completely free of charge. And he simply was one of the most prolific architects of his time, of any race. He produced thousands of projects in his 50-year career. He died in 1980, and his funeral was held in a church of his own design, filled with friends, family, and past clients. Paul R. Williams and associates continued working without him for a while.
这会把他们塑造成为不同类型的人。他做了很多慈善工作，为孩子们做了很多事情，不仅在非裔美国人社区。当他在孟菲斯设计圣裘德研究医院时，他是完全免费的。而且他简直是他那个时代、无论什么种族的最多产的建筑师之一。在他50年的职业生涯中，他制作了数千个项目。他于1980年去世，他的葬礼在他自己设计的一座教堂里举行，里面挤满了朋友、家人和过去的客户。保罗·R·威廉姆斯及其合伙人在他去世后继续无私地工作了一段时间。
Well, after he died in 1980, the office went on for a couple of years. I'm not quite sure how long it, but it essentially came to an end some time by the end of the 80s. This is Leslie Liebers of the University of Memphis. And then all of the material from his practice was stored at a branch of the Broadway Federal Savings banks. And this branch was a building Williams designed. He designed it, but the more important thing was that one of his daughters married the founder
在他于1980年去世后，事务所又运营了几年。我不太确定具体有多久，但它基本上在80年代末的某个时候走到了尽头。这是孟菲斯大学的莱斯利·利伯斯。然后，他事务所的所有材料都被存放在百老汇联邦储蓄银行的一个分行。这个分行是一座由威廉姆斯设计的建筑。他设计了它，但更重要的是，他的一个女儿嫁给了百老汇联邦银行的创始人，
of Broadway Federal, so it was essentially a family relationship. And most of Williams documents and records were just there in the bank, stored in a room. They weren't even an avult. But then, in 1992, after a group of officers were acquitted of the brutal beating of Rodney King, the city of LA erupted into violent protest. That branch of Broadway federal burned to the ground and everything in it burned to the
所以这基本上是一种亲属关系。威廉姆斯的绝大部分文件和记录就存放在银行的一个房间里。它们甚至不在保险库里。但是，在1992年，在一群警官被判无罪释放罗德尼·金残酷殴打案之后，洛杉矶市爆发了暴力抗议活动。百老汇联邦银行的那家分行被烧为平地，里面的一切也都化为乌烬，
ground, and that was pretty much the end of everything available about Paul Williams. This is where the Paul Williams project comes in. The Paul Williams project is primarily a research project that seeks to accumulate information, photographs, etc. about Paul Williams, principally his career. And a big part of this project was actually collecting information and hunting down which buildings were designed by Williams. The project, which is based at the University of Memphis, sent a photographic team to Los Angeles and Palm Springs in Las Vegas to start a catalog of Paul Williams buildings, but
那几乎宣告了所有关于保罗·威廉姆斯的现有资料的终结。这就是“保罗·威廉姆斯项目”介入的地方。“保罗·威廉姆斯项目”主要是一个研究项目，旨在收集关于保罗·威廉姆斯的信息、照片等，主要是关于他的职业生涯。这个项目的一个重要部分实际上是收集信息并追查哪些建筑是威廉姆斯设计的。该项目总部设在孟菲斯大学，派遣了一个摄影团队前往洛杉矶、棕榈泉和拉斯维加斯，开始为保罗·威廉姆斯的建筑编目，但
they were not always easy to find. Because he was a master at period style, So, you know, he would have a Spanish style house next to a colonial style house, next to a French provincial style house or Gothic style house. He'd be like, okay. The project has found less than half of William's work. Who knows how many of his buildings have been unknowingly torn down or renovated beyond recognition? And the Paul Williams project is always hearing about more buildings to add to the catalog, mostly in Los Angeles, but not exclusively.
它们并不总是那么容易找到。因为他是历史风格的大师，所以，你知道的，他会把一座西班牙风格的房子建在殖民地风格的房子旁边，旁边又是一座法国省份风格的房子或哥特式风格的房子。他会觉得，好吧。该项目发现的威廉姆斯的建筑作品不到一半。谁知道有多少他的建筑在不知不觉中被拆除或翻新得面目全非？“保罗·威廉姆斯项目”总是不断听到有更多建筑被加入到目录中，主要在洛杉矶，但不仅限于此。
William's buildings are all over the country, and there are a few abroad. We discover them all the time. And then we verify, we verify every house. So we go to the city documents, when pulling permits, all of that. They're constantly checking and correcting themselves. But it's really tough work because they have to go by accounts and records, which were mostly burned. And then Williams' style is just all over the place. He just didn't stick to one thing. He was always learning and developing.
威廉姆斯的建筑遍布全国，海外也有一些。我们一直在发现它们。然后我们核实，我们核实每一栋房子。所以我们要去查阅城市文件，调取许可证，诸如此类。他们一直在核对和修正自己。但这真的是一项艰苦的工作，因为他们必须依据那些大部分已被烧毁的账户和记录。而且威廉姆斯的风格简直无所不包。他并没有拘泥于某一种东西。他一直在学习和发展。
And of course, he would listen to his clients and try and respond to what they needed and what their desires were. That's architect Phil Freelon again. And I asked him if Williams had to be responsive to his clients and flexible in his style in order to survive as a black architect. I think that Paul Williams desired to satisfy his clients is something that many architects share and it's not necessarily tied to race, although I will point out that he had to make certain adjustments in his approach to clients because of who he was in the time period in which
当然，他会倾听客户的意见，并试图回应他们的需求和愿望。建筑师菲尔·弗里隆再次说道。我问他，为了作为一名黑人建筑师生存下来，威廉姆斯是否必须对客户保持响应并在风格上保持灵活。我认为保罗·威廉姆斯想要满足客户的愿望是许多建筑师所共有的，这不一定与种族挂钩，尽管我要指出的是，由于他的身份以及他所处时代的局限，他不得不对客户的方法做出某些调整。
he practiced. By the way, Phil Freelan is also a big deal. He worked on the Museum of the African Diaspora in San Francisco, the Center for Civil and Human Rights in Atlanta, and most recently. The National Museum of African American History and Culture on the Mall in Washington, DC, where I was the architect of record. Phil Freelahn had already gotten into an architecture program before he had even heard of Paul Williams. I was maybe into my third or fourth year of school before I learned about Paul Williams
顺便说一句，菲尔·弗里隆也是个大人物。他曾参与旧金山非裔美国人 diaspora 博物馆、亚特兰大民权和人权中心的设计，最近的作品是位于华盛顿特区国家广场上的国家非裔美国人历史和文化博物馆，我是那里的注册建筑师。菲尔·弗里隆在甚至还没听说过保罗·威廉姆斯之前就已经进入了建筑专业。我可能读到大三或大四时才知道保罗·威廉姆斯，
and that was really on my own. It wasn't anything in the curriculum or in architectural history that mentioned him. Let's make this clear. There are a lot of black architects who get left out of the textbooks. Paul Williams was not the first black architect in America, but he was the first to be accepted as a member of the AIA, the American Institute of Architects. The American Institute of Architects is the leading professional organization in the US for licensed architects and others
而且那完全是靠我自己。课程大纲或建筑史中没有任何地方提及他。让我们把这一点明确。有很多黑人建筑师被排除在教科书之外。保罗·威廉姆斯并不是美国第一位黑人建筑师，但他却是第一位被接受为 AIA（美国建筑师学会）会员的人。美国建筑师学会是美国针对持证建筑师及业内其他人士的领先专业组织。
in the profession. Paul Williams joined the AIA in 1923. And every black architect I know, they know who Paul Williams is. And I haven't met a white architect yet that knew who I was talking about if I were to mention that name. And we need to change that. And this is why Phil Freelon nominated Paul Williams for the AIA's highest individual award, the gold medal. It's basically the award that welcomes an architect
保罗·威廉姆斯于1923年加入了AIA。我认识的每一位黑人建筑师都知道保罗·威廉姆斯是谁。但我还没有遇到过哪位白人建筑师，当我提到这个名字时知道我在说什么。我们需要改变这种状况。这就是为什么菲尔·弗里隆提名保罗·威廉姆斯获得 AIA 的最高个人奖项——金奖。这基本上是把一位建筑师迎入
into the canon of all time greats. Previous winners include Frank Lloyd Wright, Mies Vandero, Luka Bucie and Thomas Jefferson. And now Paul Williams will officially join their ranks 37 years after his death. This award means a lot to Friland and other African-American architects in terms of general visibility. There are very few African-American architects
所有时代伟大人物殿堂的奖项。先前的得奖者包括弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特、密斯·凡·德罗、勒·柯布西耶和托马斯·杰斐逊。现在，保罗·威廉姆斯在他逝世37年后，将正式加入他们的行列。这个奖项对弗里隆和其他非裔美国建筑师来说，在提高整体知名度方面意义重大。相对而言，在这个国家工作的非裔美国建筑师非常少，
working in this country, relatively speaking, you know, 2% of the licensed architects in this country are black. And one of the ways you would want to combat that is to raise the visibility and to make sure people know that this is a great profession and that young people see it as a possibility and as an option for them.
你知道的，这个国家的持证建筑师中有2%是黑人。你想打击这种现象的方法之一，就是提高知名度，确保人们知道这是一个伟大的职业，并让年轻人将之视为一种可能性和他们的一种选择。
And ultimately, this award is about recognizing a master, a recognition that is long overdue. Paul Williams developed the eclectic style of the California home and helped shape the look and feel of Los Angeles just as much as Los Angeles shaped him. A man who could draw magnificent style, upside down, and better than most of his peers. 99% of visible was produced this week by Avery Truffleman, which refused Delaney Hall, Emmett Fitzgerald, and me Roman Mars. Speaking to me, Roman Mars, I'm up for a People's Choice Webby Award for Best Podcast Host,
归根结底，这个奖项是为了表彰一位大师，这是一项早已迟到的认可。保罗·威廉姆斯开创了加州住宅的折衷主义风格，并塑造了洛杉矶的面貌和氛围，正如洛杉矶塑造了他一样。一个能倒着画出宏伟风格、且比大多数同龄人都画得更好的人。本周99%可感知节目由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼制作，德莱尼·霍尔、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德和我——罗曼·马尔斯共同制作。对我说，罗曼·马尔斯，我正在竞选“人民选择网络奖”的最佳播客主持人，
so please vote for me. I would like to win that. I'll link to it in the show notes. Katie Mingle is our senior editor, Kurt Colstead is the digital director, and Terran Meza is the office manager. The all-original music in this episode was composed by Sean Rial. Special thanks this week to Taylor Hamilton, Bonnie Boswell, and Bradford Grant. We are a project of 91.7 K-A-L-W in San Francisco
所以请为我投票。我很想赢得那个奖。我会在节目简介中提供链接。凯蒂·明格是我们的高级编辑，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监，泰兰·梅扎是办公室经理。本期节目的所有原创音乐均由肖恩·里亚尔创作。本周特别感谢泰勒·汉密尔顿、邦尼·博斯韦尔和布拉德福德·格兰特。我们是旧金山 91.7 K-A-L-W 电台的一个项目，
and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars on the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram and Tumblr too. But we released at least two articles about design and architecture every week on our website at 99PI.org. Radio Topeia from PRX.
制作于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心电台街。你可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并参与有关该节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我 @Roman Mars，或@节目 99PI org。我们也在 Instagram 和 Tumblr 上。但我们每周都会在我们的网站 99PI.org 上发布至少两篇关于设计和建筑的文章。来自 PRX 的 Radio Topia。
Radio Topeo from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自 PRX 的 Radio Topia。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。